at what stage of the filmmaking process
and filmmakers bring on their marketing
team is it during the screenwriting
process is it during pre-production or
is it best just to wait until you're
finally a post production and then you
started thinking about sound on the film
you know which of these time periods
best positions the producers to have a
film that's going to successfully reach
the market so as I said that really
thinking about who your audience is and
the and I think that this is a must
misunderstanding as well that marketing
strategy is different than marketing
tactics like the things that you do in
order to market your film strategy
speaks to who and where so you don't
need a team of people to tell you that
like you need to be thinking about those
two things when you're very early into
developing your idea so there's no need
to hire a special person to tell you
about that as I said if you're thinking
about Who am I that helps you to narrow
down the strategy that you're going to
be following now you know it you can
talk to any manner of marketing people
and they will tell you oh yes well
you're thinking just too narrowly you
know we could expand out bigger wider
more more sure you can get unbelievably
wider you know in any of this but for in
general the independence that I'm that I
know and talk to you every day they
don't have unlimited resources they
can't go after this wide broad audience
so they need to think as small and tight
because that's what their resources are
really going to be best utilized for I
think that it is useful when you get
into production and you're gonna be on
the set that you are so busy doing the
actual production and running a set with
all these people who are there for a
limited amount of time and being paid
for that time that you can't be worried
about did I get all the good photos you
know did I interview each of the cast
and crew because I might want to use
those video clips later have I talked to
local people who were you know talked
about how it was to have a filming in
their community or if it's a documentary
you know there were many experts and
maybe we want to go back and enter
you some of those that person that main
marketing person is just keeping up with
those details they are not on the set to
help with any form of production of the
thing they are only there purely from
the marketing standpoint and collecting
material for that and you know hopefully
working with a photographer or whoever's
taking good stills and guiding them on
here's what I need because you don't
have time for that
and then while you go in to post that
person is sorting through all the assets
and figuring out what are we creating
with this stuff and how are we gonna
plan out how it's published you know how
often is it published and you should I
talked about this in a workshop I did
the other day with the Alliance of women
directors that you have a one 7:34 to
one content strategy which is you have
something that you do daily which is the
one you have something that you do
weekly which is the seventh you have
something that you do monthly which is a
big thing but you juice consistently
that one big thing every month and then
you have something that you do quarterly
by annually annually you know so
annually could be like your app if
you're making an iPhone app you're not
gonna do that quarterly you're gonna do
that once probably or that you're making
you know a new film once a year I don't
know how often you know that your annual
big events going to be but when you're
making out your calendar you say okay
here are the things I'm going to do
every day I'm going to have a Facebook
post maybe several
I'm gonna do Twitter have maybe several
posts to my social channels those are
everyday things and I'm gonna answer
comments that come with that or go to
blogs and look and see if there's any
comments that I can leave that are
relevant to what the people have talked
about not just there to drop in and put
your URL up once a week ideally you want
to have a blog post something new maybe
several times but if for most people
they can handle a once a week kind of
commitment like that that once a month
you can do some kind of Q&A with either
somebody who's attached to the
production of your film or who's a
participant especially if it's a
documentary participant in the film
or you know it's just sort of a longer
piece than your shorter blog posts so
that would be a once a month thing or
you have a meet-up or a Tweetup you know
where you might be in a different city
and you talk or you go and do a reddit
AMA or you do a Google hangout or
something like that once a month and
then quarterly it you know you're gonna
do well in the monthly thing you'll
probably do emails so and quarterly
you'll do like a round up of my four
best blog posts or the things that
people responded to something that sort
of takes the efforts that you've done
already and kind of put them in a better
context for people that you do you know
once every couple of months and then and
then the meetup situation is the same
something that you're doing but it's in
a bigger venue someplace that you know
you're gonna be in that quarter that you
can meet up with people and then you
know biannually it's some of this is
mixed between what you do on the
production and what you do as a person
as an artist you might do a live event
of some sort you know that you're doing
twice a year and you invite all your
best followers to come to that I mean
you you have to kind of think about it
but it helps you to space out and
organize how are how are you spending
your time so it doesn't become
overwhelming so then it just falls to
the ground which you know if you can
really space it out and then this person
really helps to do that and figure out
what are those things that we're gonna
do in that time frame and things will
always pop up that you didn't expect
that you can take advantage of but you
have sort of a set schedule otherwise
that you are following and then when you
get into Festival premiere that person
is sourcing a publicist if you want to
have an outside person who has a lot
more connections than then you have you
know if you're going to go for a sales
agent then you're working with that
person at your premiere and hoping to
get a sale always have your plan be that
the sale is great if it happens but not
dead in the water if it doesn't you know
so within three months
if you don't think there's if there's no
sales prospect at the place where you've
premiered and within three months you're
going to be launching it you're going to
be launching on your own site if nothing
or getting it ready for iTunes through
an aggregator or getting it for Netflix
with an aggregator or doing your own
theatrical tour and you're gonna start
booking theaters or using Tugg or
something like that
so there is a plan which can be scrapped
if another opportunity that's better
than what you're planning comes along
but you're not dead if you if that
opportunity doesn't come so I think that
you it having a team depends on how big
ever released you're planning to have
but I don't think that you need to bring
someone in as in a full-time capacity or
somebody who's totally devoted to this
job until you're about in production
stage if you have a very clear idea
about who you're going after cuz that
person just walking in to the set it's
like okay what are we collecting you
know who is this for what are we gonna
be using I mean you do have to have a
marketing plan you do have to have a
budget so you can say well I'm not gonna
have any money to do video cuts later or
I won't have any really much of a budget
to do Facebook ads or something like
that so we won't be using those that's
not part of our plan because we don't
have a budget for that so you don't have
to hire somebody full-time to get one of
those plans but you probably do want to
have somebody more full-time to help
implement those plans
you